our next guest is a serial entrepreneur
with the ultimate rags to rich life
story
being forced to flee iran as a child
with his family to survive
he ended up spending part of his
childhood in a refugee camp in germany
after eventually making it to the usa
and serving his new country with 101st
airborne division of the us army
he continued to advance building an
empire that gives so much to so many
today he is the ceo of php agency
incorporated
a financial services agency with over 12
000 agents
in both the us and puerto rico for many
of us around the world
we know him as the leader and presenter
of the youtube channel valuetainment
that has nearly 3 million subscribers
and growing fast
beyond sharing his business financial
social commentary and entrepreneurial
insights he also interviews the widest
variety and most interesting guests
of any channel i have ever seen from
infamous figures such as kobe bryant
jordan peterson peter schiff robert
kiyosaki and ben shapiro
to former military generals snipers
undercover fbi agents reformed
high-ranking criminals
and even a north korean defector he
never ceases to deliver the most
intriguing commentary and insight on
nearly every topic
father husband veteran millionaire
teacher leader entrepreneur and all
around top bloke
he is patrickbetdavid pat i
am absolutely honored to meet you thanks
for coming to the channel
great intro it's great to be with you
pat i acknowledge that
you got into i guess your riches from
the insurance industry
but i think most people around the world
is fair to say that we know you from
your work on valuetainment
now i know that you're not very big on
too many compliments but
i also understand that you're big on
values and one of my values is to really
give respect where respect
is due and i'd like to start off by
saying thank you for what you do for all
of us
thank you for what you teach us and
thank you for giving it to us for free
any time and it's so funny you said i
don't like compliments but i'll take
that one thank you
thank you look i want to share a quick
story with you an icebreaker if i may
last year i was in a desert i won't say
too much but i was in the middle east in
the gym working out at one o'clock in
the morning i think you
can probably figure out what the
background to that is i want to talk
about your most
memorable interview for me and i want to
see if you can guess which one it is
now it wasn't the most informative but
it was the most interesting
so i'm in a gym it's one o'clock in the
morning i'm lifting
i'm in the middle of my session and i
had to stop to actually look at my phone
to actually see what was happening in
your interview was real
it got heated it started in one
direction
it started to go down another direction
and i had to replay this thing
it blew my mind i'm glad that you
published it
it went from good to bad to worse but
you stood your ground and you held your
values
do you know what conversation i'm
talking about lucian trusca
oh of course that was the one brother
as i said it wasn't the most informative
but certainly the most memorable
can you tell me a little bit about that
in the sense that i can see that
whenever you interview someone you do
the right thing by
looking in their background you afford
them a chance to
give their values and their opinion but
what went wrong with that interview
you know it's funny when we were
speaking offline uh typically i'll go a
couple minutes to establish some kind of
a relationship with the viewer and i'll
you know
with the person i'm interviewing do you
know what we stand for do you know the
audience do you know what we are
all this stuff great so we got started
and right off the bat within three
minutes he was triggered
i never said to tear down the statue
i said to i said okay let's just say you
said to remove it
and then every time we were going it
almost seemed like he was getting more
and more upset
and uh by the 10th minute i think he was
telling himself i should have never said
yes to this interview
because he didn't do his proper due
diligence on the interview
knowing the fact that we interview a lot
of interesting people and we're not one
of those channels that says
tell us the key to success you know like
even yourself look at the question you
just started off with
you just started off with a great
question no one's ever starting an
interview with the question you just
asked right now right
you ask the question and you make it
interesting for me
but for him he typically only did
interviews with people that agreed with
his position
he never did any interviews with people
that didn't agree with his position
and i no matter whether i agree with you
or not i'm still going to ask questions
as if i disagree with you sometimes i
agree with you but that's not
the interviewee sometimes doesn't know
that i do it because
it's the one way to get the audience to
make a decision for themselves by
hearing some of the
opposing arguments so within the first
three minutes we knew it was going to be
an interesting interview
well what i certainly got out of it
wasn't so much the content that he gave
but
how you taught us how to handle that
situation and to hold your ground
maintain your values
and really in the end just as you
described you do what you do they're the
guest in your house
i am curious so did he ask you to take
it down did he ask you not to publish it
no
nothing and by the way there was a lot
worse stuff that we didn't publish it i
mean
at the end when you saw him say what he
said it went for another
10 minutes like that we just cut it he
would not stop
but then i said if we show more than
that it's going to be a
humiliating situation i wasn't going to
do that he went into some very bad
places that would have hurt this
character
i just said i'm just going to leave the
last part and we're not the rest of the
5 10 minutes
well it certainly interrupted my workout
session but i had to stop what i was
doing
i had to put my phone on the dumbbell
rack and change what i was doing so i
could actually see it
and i normally listen in two times speed
but because it was just so intriguing i
actually watched it in real time speed
but
look moving on before we get to some
very serious global issues i wanted to
point out
one of your videos in particular plot
your next 15 moves was awesome
so to my subscribers if you haven't seen
patrick's work you must watch some of
the stuff that he gives us
in many ways you're my mentor in many
ways you have taught me a lot of things
that i thought i should have known
stuff that i should have learned in
university and my in my degrees and my
masters
you're giving me a lot and i want to
talk about university in a second but
one point in particular
point four point five and plot your next
15 moves was about having enemies
now do you think the bigger you become
the more
enemies you attract and in that video
you also mentioned
it's almost part of the journey is it
inevitable to have enemies
yeah it is it's so funny you say that
last night we were having
we were having sushi with myself adam
mario and kai
and we were talking about enemies and i
said the challenge about enemies
is the following there are certain
enemies
that you can only avoid by not being
relevant
and not competing in a marketplace so if
you don't have any enemies just don't do
anything
you know just play small and just live a
regular average and ordinary life
but if you do that your biggest enemy
becomes
the man in the mirror or the woman in
the mirror because
your spirit is furious with you for you
not wanting to give your best so there's
nobody worse that's going to be your
enemy
than yourself now let's talk about the
second kind of enemies
you decided to go into real estate you
decide to be a podcaster you decide to
go and do insurance investment stocks
bonds digital media you decide to go
into pharmaceutical sales you decide to
do
you know engineer coding
and you want to be the best at it one of
the best at it
you go in you're going to piss people
off because you're going to take mark
your chair away
attention away eyeballs away they're
going to bring up your name
some of the old-timers gonna hear about
your name they hate being compared to
you
they hate saying well you know how about
this new guy oh you know they hate it
right they can't stand it because you're
taking
that away you can't avoid that that part
you cannot avoid now
then there's the third kind the third
kind are the kind of enemies that
should be avoided but you due to
self-inflicted comments or things you
did you created those enemies now if
they're intentional
more power to you for example let's just
say if megan merkel goes out there and
says what she says
and she intentionally wants
the royal family to be her number one
enemy
because she wants to get 100 million
plus views so she can get that 110
million dollar contract with netflix
to set up her next career now she's
living in montecito
next to oprah winfrey and everybody else
well you knew what you were doing and it
was intentional
but if you're not doing it intentionally
you just made a mistake and gave birth
to seven new
enemies that you could have avoided you
know you have to be careful of creating
those enemies and i will tell you this
the most dangerous types of people
you'll ever face
most people think you know my gosh i
have to worry about that guy that's
working so hard
i have to worry about that guy i have to
worry about that visionary you don't
have to worry about those guys at all
the people you have to worry about as
competitors and enemies
are extremely ambitious lazy people
those who are extremely ambitious they
think big okay
they think very highly of themselves
like you even see them walking around
like a little bit pompous
arrogant you're like why do you look at
me like you think you're better than me
you haven't done anything crazy with
your life
but in their mind they're better than
everybody else they're ambitious right
but deep down inside they don't want to
put in the work they think big
they they're visionaries they have big
ideas
they're talented they just don't want to
work
hard if there's any kind of enemies you
don't want to give birth
to are the lazy ambitious people
those guys will haunt you for the rest
of your life
they're very weird people on how they
are everybody else you can't avoid some
of the people you compete
it's going to be normal i think from
what i got from what you're saying is
that
they can actually drive you to do better
and enemies in fact
form part of your journey to your
success can you comment on resilience
i'm wondering because we're in this
touchy-feely society where it's getting
so much softer it links to resilience
for me
when people come across enemies they
trip out and certainly in australia we
make so many laws where we just don't
allow any
anyone to face anything that's of a
difficult nature are we becoming less
resilient as a society
there's no question about it there's no
question about it i posted something on
facebook the other day about debate
and i said one of the greatest things
in life is debate you know i i'd much
rather watch
a two-hour debate of the hitchens
brothers debating god the existence of
gods three hours on youtube the two
brothers one's a christian one's a
catholic believes in god
the other wasn't an atheist doesn't
believe in god you watch that three-hour
debate you're gonna learn more from that
three-hour debate then
you would go into college taking a
semester in theology
because debate is what we need and by
the time you're done watching that
debate you're going to walk away and
you're going to say
you know what i don't agree with what
hitches said as an atheist and and i
i'm an atheist but i don't i don't think
that argument was that strong because
his brother said this but you know his
brother said something about god the
existence of god and virgin mary and
jesus
i kind of like what chris hitchens said
to that but you know what i'm walking
away saying
i used to not believe there's a god i
think there is a god
i think there's more of a god today than
i thought yesterday or you're gonna walk
away you're gonna say
you know i still believe in god i i
don't know if i believe in it as much as
i do right because we had debate right
here's what debate does the beautiful
power of debate is the following
put a democrat on a republican let him
debate put a christian
an atheist put a a person that believes
in pro-life
pro-choice guns no guns military no
military war to protect the country
no war world peace somebody that
believes in apple somebody that believes
in droids somebody that loves soccer
somebody
loves football put him in a room let him
debate
let us watch it you know what it does to
the audience it's the craziest thing
so all the extremes who are far right
or far left what a great debate does
it brings us inner it doesn't bring us
all the way in it doesn't even get us to
tip to the other side
but it just gets our extremes to be a
little bit smaller
and smaller and the further we get to
the center the more we get to the center
the more reasonable we are
and the more reasonable we are the
easier it is for us to
communicate with each other and deal
with each other and understand each
other's differences
but what looks like that's happening
right now with all the sensitivity and
the pierce morgan and all this other
stuff
we're eliminating debate and it's gonna
make the next generation dumber
unfortunately i think you've put that
really well because
debate as you said it actually brings us
together and if it doesn't bring us all
the way together it at least gives us
empathy where we can understand
what the other side is saying and
perhaps why they're even thinking it
i get a lot out of peter shift so i'm
very big into bitcoin my
channel is primarily focused on money
economics and crypto and why i enjoy
watching peter schiff
is because i don't agree with what he
says but he has the courage and
professionalism
to come forth into the crypto community
and say i don't believe in it for these
reasons and he doesn't get offended
when we talk about why we believe in it
and equally we don't get offended why
he does or doesn't believe in gold or
what's going to be the future of money
but ultimately i'm concerned that we're
shutting down debate
which results in the shutting down of
free speech and democracy
which actually links into what i'd like
to talk about now two of your big videos
i want to go to a bit of a strategic
level if i may so
one video that you released just this
week i have been preparing for this
interview for
for weeks but then i watch one of your
videos i'm like i have to include this
and that's called is new york the next
detroit
now this is also going to link to your
interview with brigadier general robert
spalding about
china's silent takeover while america's
elite sleeps
let me share a little story with you if
i may so i studied in university in
america for a while at pepperdine i
believe
pepperdine was the university very one
of your co-authors went there i believe
oh yeah last virgin is one of my co-one
of the authors his
daughter went there and tom ellsworth
used to teach at pepperdine
that's a phenomenal university and a
magical campus i i used to dream about
that place a long time after i left it's
over the pacific ocean
but one of my classes had my most
memorable classes of all my degrees
everywhere in the world was
entrepreneurial studies
now my teacher richard phillips he said
where should we test a product if we're
going to test a new global product where
should we test it in the world
and everyone's putting their hands up
with all these recommendations but in
the end i remember so clearly he said
right here this is where we test a new
product right here in la and then it
goes from there
now i'm not talking about a product here
what i'm talking about is a societal
view on how things are working
so what was very concerning to me over
the last few years is watching people
exit los angeles california at large
and it rang back to what my professor
was saying at pepperdine was
this is where we test a product now that
product in this instance is in fact in
my opinion
political opinion and political unrest
so we saw the mass exodus
from california then we saw the mass
exodus from new york
then in your latest video you spoke
about the mass exodus
from detroit where you know those stats
that you read were just blowing my mind
away the amount of empty buildings
the um i think it was a 50-minute call
out time for police
and then at the end yeah and then at the
end of the video the most powerful thing
that you said to me was
don't let politics get into your family
don't let the
politics influence what your partner is
thinking or saying is like
why aren't you doing this why aren't we
doing that keep the politics out
my question to you my friend is is this
bigger than just what's happening in
america is this the erosion of the west
and is it being done perhaps through
ideological subversion as yuri besmanov
speaks about in his work oh
man it's it's it's a it's a scary
thought because because
the following reason you know when a kid
comes from money he doesn't understand
if the father didn't raise him right he
doesn't understand how
hard it is to make money i had a guy i
interviewed with
he was a psychologist and a planner for
families who were billionaires one of
the families was
uh the templeton family the family is
worth 6 billion
and 16 of the grandkids i think out of
the 16
15 of them became drug addicts and
ruined their lives and i think one of
them that was left
he was working with and he said i said
how can you save those kids he says it's
too late he says bad
the way to save those kids is very very
earliest what do you mean
he said the biggest challenge with these
kids is they got everything they wanted
they got the card they got the house
they got the toys they party they
were on other rich people they hooked up
with other rich people's daughters and
they went over this and they
everything came easy to them right and
then later on you're trying to teach
them character
and you realize they never learned it
there's a book i read many years ago
called
ultimate gift written by a guy named
gemma stovall
it's a story about a guy named ray
stevens
and he's a guy that goes and works at an
oil field
eventually the owner of that field dies
he strikes oil he becomes a billionaire
and then when he becomes a billionaire
he shoots
a video that will only be played
when he dies so
one day he dies and he is attorney that
was his best friend for 40 years
he invites him over to the house and he
says rhett stephens not roy rhett
stevens wants to talk to you
and he puts in the vhs tape and rhett
says
if you're here right now he's going like
this if you're here right now
it's because i'm dead okay and you're
wondering
what i'm going to do with the 2.2
billion dollars and who it's going to go
to
so let me break it to you he says
unfortunately i've spoiled all of you
his wife is there his daughter's there
everybody's there
so he says to my son i'm gonna give you
all my properties with one exception
the janitor has more say on the
properties than you and you can never
sell the properties
but you own them i'm going to give my
investment portfolio to my daughter
but guess what the investment banker
says what you do with the money not you
i'm going to give my company to it so he
goes through all this stuff and he gives
away
and at the end his nephew's left and he
says for you
i have the ultimate gift and the
ultimate gift
i don't have a car i don't have a house
i don't have a company to give you
the ultimate gift starts on monday
tuesday when you come here i have 12
videos for you to watch
each week you're going to get a
challenge on tuesday if you take it
by the 12th month i'm going to give you
the ultimate gift
he says the reason why before you walk
out because you're upset that i don't
have any money to give you
is because you're the only one that i
didn't over spoil
right what a ridiculous story
anyways the nephew is struggling with it
i don't know if i'm gonna do it or not
he comes i'm not gonna spoil the whole
story for you but the point is
america is red stevens and america has
spoiled
everybody yes let's give unemployment
for this long yes let's give
hey fdr came out with social security he
only came up with social security for a
few thousand people he didn't come up
with social security for everybody and
when he came out with social security
the average life expectancy in america
was like mid 60s
and he started social security at 62
which means he only got
social security for three years that
means it's as if today the life
expectancy in america is 80
if fdr was alive today social security
would have started at 77.
but no today it's like hey more because
we have money more because we have money
more because america's so wealthy
let's just keep throwing free money out
another stimulus 1.9 trillion another
900 billion another 1.9 trillion
to the point where in the last 13 or 12
months america
in the last 12 months has printed
40 percent of all the currency america's
ever had let me say that one more time
40 of all the currency america's ever
had was printed in the last 12 months
which guess who it favors those who
those of you that believe in bitcoin
that's a perfect argument for you
also gold but it's a perfect argument
for you this is why the dollar
is getting a black eye right now the
more we print
so for me i am very much concerned when
i see an aoc
and you go out there in aoc great market
a greater telling her stories
and just a year ago this girl had a
couple million followers on twitter
and today she has 12.6 million followers
on twitter
and she's young she's a representative
of bronx and queens
and she has so much say what does this
mean we didn't have this kind of
momentum with socialism 40 years ago
communism and socialism the ideas have
been around for a long time since karl
marx when he wrote the book and
you know marxism communism socialism
those ideas have been on for a while
but today due to social media
people are looking at somebody and
saying wow 12.6 million followers
she must really know what she's talking
about maybe the social something's not
really not bad so then that leads me to
my concern of okay
if you live in california you're not
happy where you're at you go to texas
if you live in detroit they mistreat you
you go to
texas if you're in new york they
mistreat you you go to florida
if you're in illinois they mistreat you
you go to tennessee so
you know california you can go to nevada
because there's no state taxes the point
is
if i don't like a state i can go to a
different place i have the options
but what if it gets to a point that
eventually the federal government that
mistreats you where do you go to next
that's right you go to costa rica
do you go to dubai do you go to
singapore do you go to new zealand
where do you go do you go to camp where
do you go where do you go
so you know i would be more comfortable
if i knew
that like if today
i always say this if somebody were to
give me 10 million people in a good
amount of land
a country we would recruit the most
incredible minds and make it very
difficult to get into that country
because you would only be able to get
into that country that you bring value
to the table and we don't care if people
don't like it
but within two decades we would be the
place
everybody would want to live in because
we would build it right off the bat with
certain values and principles to protect
unfortunately today that option number
two is not very obvious
there are option number two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
but it's not as obvious so america has
the ability to bully
its own citizens because what are you
gonna do i dare you to leave america
where are you gonna go
and they're right today so if a handful
of countries took advantage of that
it's like working at google google
mistreats you go to facebook but imagine
if there's only one google
where are you gonna go if google
mistreats you you don't have a choice
they're paying you pretty well you're
gonna go anywhere else so
america's bullying right now and uh i
don't know how long it's gonna last i'm
always pro creator pro builder
uh a builder is always gonna be wanted
in a country a creator is always gonna
be wanted in a country they're never
they're never ever single everybody
always wants to be with a builder and a
creator
but one country or two need to really
level up their game today because
there's a lot of talent that could
potentially go to them
this is where your work comes into it i
think so we were speaking about debate
before
so certainly at university debate seems
to be
shut down so much like you can only have
one opinion and if you go against
the mainstream opinion you're a bigot
you're a racist you're a xenophobe
and it actually stops debate and it
stops this
ability to to think outside the box and
that's why we have this kind of push
towards socialism perhaps
now when you spoke about the money
printing press where we become
reliant on the daddy state the daddy
state that will give us lots of money
and we don't need to work and we don't
need to worry about anything because the
printing press will just
give us more money i recently released a
video called
printing press goes bur bitcoin goes
boom and
what i'm talking about in that video is
the more money that
the printing press pumps out the more
people are forced into a harder money
such as bitcoin
whether they like bitcoin or not it's in
two ways what i'm finding now is people
are shifting into bitcoin
not because they think they can buy a
lamborghini but because there's no other
choice
it is now at a point that if you keep
your money in cash it's becoming
it's becoming a liability it's
financially irresponsible to not at
least have some bitcoin
as people are fleeing out of the us
dollar and trying to run
to a new money which is bitcoin what are
your thoughts on the future of money if
america keeps printing it
and america keeps pushing everyone into
a corner to go a certain way
and people do flee the states at a
national level and then at a federal
level going somewhere else
when will it stop do you think there
could be a war on the horizon
oh i mean of course i mean look look at
one of the things right now with bitcoin
they're trying to find out how to
regulate bitcoin janet yellen is trying
to do whatever she can to get a hold of
bitcoin for five years
if you see anybody asking about bitcoin
watch what's been my biggest concern
every single time they're gonna try to
regulate it they're gonna try to
regulate it that's the biggest thing
because that's what the government likes
to do
they like to regulate gold they like to
regulate bitcoin they like to regulate
anything and everything they can get
their hands on to administrate so
um i don't know i think i can tell you
one thing for a fact
is today if there's ever been an era
where all the bitcoin people are
laughing saying i told you so today's
the day like all the bitcoin pro bitcoin
people ought to go on twitter and say i
told you so
hashtag bitcoin they have the right to
do so because
they can say that today now
remember how earlier i talked to you
about the most dangerous people you'll
ever face are lazy ambitious people
yeah regulators and politicians are
exactly that
they're the lazy ambitious people they
hate the fact that you came up with an
idea that you don't need somebody to
take care of you they hate the fact that
you don't need
a guy in your pocket to finance your
election or whatever your campaign they
hate the fact that
they're not willing to work seven to ten
o'clock at night to build a business and
go sell it for a hundred million dollars
five years later or ten years later for
a billion dollars
they hate that because they're not going
to do that that's not what they're going
to do
so what do they do do they go behind
closers and say i'm going to go get
power
you want all the freedom i'm going to be
able to push you around because i'll
have the power
i make the laws i'm the lawmaker and i
can make laws to make your life
a living hell that's how they do it
so bitcoin's biggest enemy is going to
be
the lawmakers the politicians
governments that are going to want to
get into it
the benefit i hope elon musk supports
you guys and stays that way it doesn't
go back and forth doesn't kind of like
because you guys need a very strong
supporter
on your end to prevent these other guys
from getting away the good news right
now is jp morgan chase just officially
put
35 or 34 job postings online
for people that are experts in
blockchain and you know quite frankly
morgan stanley only put two and goldman
sachs only put two
but jp morgan chase put 3435 about he's
like what wait what
jp morgan is hiring 34 blockchain
experts yes
why well they're coming out with their
own bitcoin so the more these stories
happens then you have the allies
when it gets to a point where they're
facing off the enemies
that's where you benefit but you have to
also be thinking about
if they come out with their own crypto
say jpmorgan chase comes out with their
own crypto
do you think behind closed doors they
would support some of the politicians to
hurt the bitcoin brand because they're
not bitcoin they're a different crypto
i don't know all i'm saying to you is
you have to pay
very very close attention to the
lawmakers and the lazy ambitious people
because they're the ones that are
probably going to try to make your life
a living hell
so with what robert spalding was saying
about
china being perhaps the greatest threat
to the us at the moment in his book and
in his interview
i found that very confronting what he
was talking about so in my opinion
i think we've got this perfect storm we
have the opinions of
ex-generals such as spalding saying
china is a threat
we have the collapse of the petro dollar
and the us dollar as people are fleeing
out
we have civil unrest within the united
states and western nations at large
where we shut down debate and move more
to one side and even promote socialism
what is the tipping point will there be
a war
what's that about will their reward
there is war right now we are in war
it's just a different kind of work like
for example
you ever been to a family gathering
where there's a lot of politics involved
but if you didn't know about it you
would never know there's a war going on
i don't know if you know what i'm
talking about like let's just
go to a family gathering yeah when you
bring your partner they think
everything's good on the surface but you
know what's going on in the background
well i'm even talking
dirtier than that i'm talking about you
go to a family gathering
and you know your mom and your dad's
sister
hate each other like you've seen the
fight
nobody else has seen it they just called
each other you know the worst
word just a week ago but at a family
gathering like hey how are you
so how's your kids by the way i just
want you to know my son just graduated
from usc
oh congratulations to your son what
she's trying to say is hey you idiot
my son is better than your son i'm a
better parent than you and the uh
auntie responds and says oh guess what
what our son just bought his own first
house we're so proud of him that he's so
independent that they
doesn't lean on his mommy and daddy for
everything we like that we have so much
respect for our son
and you're just kind of standing there
you're saying mom and auntie are going
at it right there's a lot of work going
on
but if you don't know the inner detail
stories of what's going on you wouldn't
know about it okay so where am i going
with this
so right now we have so many proxy wars
it's not even funny
it's proxy war galore today is what we
have
uh we have so many cyber wars right now
it's not funny
not even funny uh china to microsoft
russia threatening twitter that's cyber
they're going and they're attacking them
that way
very easy we have bio warfare wars that
could happen at any given time the wars
of today are not going to be the kind of
wars that we had in world war ii or
world war one
it's going to be the kind of war that
you can't figure out who attacked you
you know you know how you fight a person
and
you're standing up and you're like hey
you want to go and he punches you in the
face
you know who hits you this is the kind
of fight
where you get hit in the back of the
head you don't know who hit you you get
stabbed you don't know who stabbed you
you're all of a sudden sick you don't
know how you got sick
it's a very dirty word today because
nobody can that the fingerprints aren't
anywhere
like imagine somebody robs your house
you call the cops they come what do they
do
well let me see this here fingerprints
put it in their thumb okay
it's a guy named john doe who lives on
42nd and broadway let's go to his house
right now they pull up
oh he's running from the back get him
hey
finger this is your shoes yes you're up
you're going to jail you have all the
laptops you stole no i sold it to the
pawn shop well then you're doing jail
time for one year
there's no fingerprints today no
fingerprints today
so it's a it's a very very weird time
today it's
like trump was a president right and
he would have been a phenomenal
president
in the 50s the 60s
because he wouldn't have a way to
constantly share his thoughts on twitter
24 7.
but he would have still been a strong
president on tv but today
he created way too many new enemies we
didn't need
he kept giving birth to new enemies i
don't know if that makes sense or not he
was
constantly pissing off old enemies and
waking him up
i get that like it's it's very much we
admire look at him he's not afraid of
anybody it's great but it's like
i totally get it i understand i admire
too i love the fact that somebody says
no i'm standing up yes stand up
but but don't give birth to new enemies
somebody today has to be a diplomat you
know
that turns enemies into allies into
friends
somebody has to be a synergist today
that just kind of calms the nerves and
it's not biden okay it's not abiding
it's not an obama it's not a trump
it's it's not it's got to be a different
kind of a personality
but uh you know it's it's a very very
random weird time today somebody has to
be the combination of strength
poise yet at the same time their
ambitions
is to unite and create a
environment where there's confidence and
diplomacy
versus their ambition being i have to be
the most powerful man in the world that
this is this
that's a wrong kind of a time to be a
leader
anyways i mean probably i'm not even
making any sense to the viewer i don't
even know if i'm making sense to you
right now but all i'm trying to say
today is
it's a lot of wars going on that we
cannot see publicly
you can't spot the fingerprints and
it's a time that gives birth to a lot of
extreme personalities and unfortunately
that's the last thing we need today it's
the last thing we need today
it makes perfect sense to me
unfortunately it makes too much sense
and it's uh it's quite scary
especially as you're saying that in the
olden days you could you could see your
adversary uh the good analogy is of
course is that fight in australia we
have a term called sucker punch or
coward punch where someone comes up
behind you and punches you in the back
of the head
you hit the ground you don't even know
what's happened and i think that is
happening on the global
stage in one of your videos the industry
is facing massive disruption
you spoke about 10 things that were
restaurant movie theaters
telecommunications cars wallets
retailers insurance
traditional journalism college sports
gas stations but then you put an 11th
one
and that was really really powerful what
you said was
given social media and where we are at
the moment and the social commentary and
the followership
from people who may not know better
there is a likelihood that we could in
fact see
a 35 year old president of the united
states
and when i heard that it just blew my
mind because i'm like this guy's dead
right
it's dead right because we've shut down
debate in university
we now just live on twitter and social
media people don't know what's really
happening in the background
mainstream has said go for this person
so we just do
and before you know it you've got
someone who does know how to use social
media
they are young and influenced by
whatever's been happening at university
they have been shut down from debate and
before we know it we don't have the
leader that you just described before
that the world needs
i thought that was powerful pat i know
you've got a lot on so if you don't mind
i'd like to close off with
15 rapid questions sure you're familiar
with how this works
i seek a one-word answer less than five
is okay but
one is preferable you can pass on any
and revisit if you like
rapid round bitcoin
not going away gold
get some the us dollar
scary college degrees
unnecessary the current global pandemic
could have been prevented trump
necessary bad timing biden
not the president democracy
in danger a world war three
very different true or false
true leaders are born not created
uh
false number eleven compulsory national
service in peacetime
pass the future of youtube
not going away anytime soon your most
memorable interview
samuel gravano an early retirement
never and number 15 this interview
fantastic all right i'm hoping
you're fantastic thank you by the way
when i said biden not the president
what i mean by that is it's the
influential people behind closed doors
that are running america today not him i
didn't mean they said mine has nothing
to do with
whether it was a fair election or not
i've already shared my position on that
it's about the fact that he's not the
real decision maker
others are making it for him i think at
a minimum we just don't see him in front
of the camera
you had trump as one extreme that he was
constantly tweeting 24 7
but with biden it's just like where's
the president of the free world
where's the leader i don't see him yeah
but look uh pat as i said i'm immensely
grateful not only for your
time with me today you prove that you
give
knowledge as well as giving to the
people who want to learn more from you
in an interview such as this
before we do close off how can we learn
more about you how can we get more from
valuetainment and from pat
i think if you want to order the book
you can go to amazon or barnes and noble
or
apple to get the audible they can get
your next five months this will kind of
give you an idea how i think
and then if you want to you know see the
content it's on youtube and if you want
to message me uh message me on twitter
patrick but david i do respond i must
admit i was impressed with one of your
videos when you actually did a
job call out for people during a youtube
video that you made i'm like i've never
seen that before
and you actually gave your phone number
i thought that was brilliant and i'm
sure you attracted a lot of the talent
from doing so
all right patrick thank you so much for
those of you who haven't met me my name
is adam stokes links below
also i will leave links to valuetainment
and everything pat
pat thank you so much for joining us
fantastic interview
thank you